una clara persecución contra el ex
presidente de evo morales y sus
seguidores esto es de lo que la ong
human rights watch acusa al gobierno
interino de bolivia gobierno actual
interino de bolivia abusa del sistema de
justicia para perseguir a colaboradores
y a partidarios del ex presidente evo
morales quien enfrenta cargos por
terrorismo que a la luz de las pruebas
parecen responder más bien a
motivaciones políticas de acuerdo con la
organización la acusación contra morales
por terrorismo es desproporcional y debe
ser retirada asimismo indica que en
bolivia se ve un abuso de poder en casos
específicos su gobierno ha presionado de
forma pública a fiscales y jueces para
que actúen de manera favorable a sus
objetivos dando lugar a investigaciones
penales contra más de 100 personas
vinculadas
al gobierno de evo morales o
simpatizantes por supuestos delitos de
sedición o terrorismo el ejecutivo negó
categóricamente lo afirmado por la ong
un ex presidente ordenó cercar la ciudad
no permitir el paso de alimento a un
país que él mismo gobernaba y llamaba a
su pueblo todo por un simple afán de
poder los abogados que prepararon la
denuncia solventaron argumentos
jurídicos para denunciar a evo morales
por terrorismo el informe se presenta
días después de que la presidenta
interina jeanine áñez reiterará que si
morales vuelve a bolivia enfrentará a
las órdenes emitidas por la fiscalía
para comparecer por varios procesos en
su contra
[Música]